volonté de séparer la société de faire
en sorte que la société se fractionne
d'une part et qu'il y a une part de
cette société qui soit totalement
d'islamiser de riskanalyst dans un
premier temps voire la société elle-même
si l'on en croit ce qui cette volonté de
prendre les rênes de la quick bar à une
religion en l'occurrence religion parti
action a aussi une religion qui s'est
totalement notamment ravi qualités
fondamentales ise et qui mêle à la fois
religion soit par méconnaissance soit
peut-être par idéologie c'est vrai que
les choses n'ont pas été dit on s'en
doute c'est une bonne intention des
pavés ne pas stigmatiser nous a montré
du doigt une religion ou une partie des
sociétés en refusant devant d'aisance
d'allemands la réalité profonde de la
situation
oui c'est amusant radical oui c'est un
islam police lane et politique mais
celui là est d'autant plus politique
peut-être menaçant ses excroissances qui
sont dangereuses pour la société sont
donc je revienne pour la vie je crois
qu'à un moment donné les cités et
appeler les choses par leur nom
simplement
[Musique]
c'est un choix politique qui est plutôt
de viser la volonté de se séparer la
république de se séparer d'un choix de
société donc de viser un communautarisme
qui le permette utilisait également un
cerf sert aussi et qui serait plutôt un
repli repli sur soi même j'ai
l'impression mais ce n'est plus mon
impression il y aurait d'un côté une
vision une visée politique par le
séparatisme
le communautarisme lui est un lutteur
dans sociétale et disons plutôt des
formes de vie de repli sur soi
accompagnées généralement de ses
mélodies de façon de vivre qui est hors
la loi